-Our next guest is a "New York
Times" best-selling author,
Politico's White House bureau
chief and the host of
"Way Too Early," which airs
weekdays at 5:00 a.m. on MSNBC.
Please welcome to the show
Jonathan Lemire, everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm so happy to have you here.
I know at this point,
it's already been
a very long day for you.
-Yeah, it's past my bedtime.
-It's past your bedtime.
What time --
First of all, I really like that
the title of your show
"Way Too Early" is obvious --
it's honest I should say
about exactly when it's on TV.
-Yeah, it is truth
in advertising.
It is 5:00 a.m. Eastern.
It is a great thing to be able
to start the day,
presenting the news of the day,
what people need to know
as they're getting ready
for their day,
but, Seth, it is --
it is way too early.
-Yeah, so what time do you
actually have to
set an alarm in the morning?
-So, my schedule in the morning
is the alarm goes off
at 3:10 a.m.
[ Audience groans ]
And at 3:11 a.m., I question
all of my life's decisions.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-That's followed by a few sort
of incoherent snoozes
and some coffee, and try not to
spill it on myself
as I get dressed in the dark.
I will say, though, coming into
the studio here at Rock Center,
or if I'm in D.C.,
no traffic at that hour.
-Really?
-Yeah, yeah.
-So that's sort of a --
-You sail right in.
-New York City life hack.
-Yeah.
-It is very nice because I think
the most helpful time
for a lot of people to get
their news would be
first thing of the day, right?
These are the things they need
to be aware of today.
Have you had people come up
to you with an appreciation?
Obviously, there's a certain
kind of person who's watching
the news at 5:00 in the morning.
They must appreciate that
there's someone like you
who's, you know, putting
their effort into it.
-Insomniacs. That's the word
you're looking for.
We do get some night owls from
the West Coast who haven't gone
to bed yet but we do; there are
people who are up early
because their days start early,
and that could be
a corporate CEO or someone,
you know, driving a city bus.
And we try to deliver that news
to everyone.
It is a start to the day.
And we know mornings
are about routines,
you're trying to get out
the door, and my show,
and then I'm around on "Morning
Joe" afterwards for a few hours.
It is -- It's a responsibility
that we take seriously.
-And what time do you go to bed?
-So the goal is around
9:00 p.m.,
which is still not
nearly enough sleep,
and I know that, but we --
you know, two kids at home,
two boys, 11 and 8,
so that's pushing it,
because their bedtime
is supposed to be 8:30,
quarter to 9:00.
Sometimes, they get a kick out
of tucking Dad into bed
and then they get to play
another hour of "Mario Kart."
-You also --
You've obviously been
a traveling reporter as well.
You covered the 2016
presidential campaign.
You received a lot of attention
for a question
you asked
Donald Trump in Helsinki,
when he was on stage,
very famously,
with Russian President
Vladimir Putin.
Can you tell us a little bit
about the question
and what it was like
in the moment
as you were asking
those two gentlemen?
-Sure, so this is
the summer of 2018.
This was then-president Trump's
much anticipated first
and only summit
with Vladimir Putin.
There, of course, had been
questions for years
about what connections
he may have to Russia.
This was the height
of the Mueller probe,
the investigation into his ties
there, potential ties to Moscow,
and I was at the Associated
Press at the time.
And it was, you know,
it's a limited press conference.
Only a couple reporters
got questions.
And I was called on.
And I asked --
-Did you know?
Is that something where you know
or do you have a sense?
-No, no.
-Okay.
-You don't.
I mean, it's --
I certainly had been
petitioning to say
that I'd like to get a question.
This is a big moment, important
things need to be asked
but you don't know until that --
until that moment.
Often, Donald Trump would try --
choose not to answer
my questions.
He would go out of his way
to ignore.
-Usually, he's such a straight
shooter. That's weird.
-Yeah, it was surprising.
-He was probably jet-lagged.
-Yeah, maybe
that's what it was.
But he did this time and the way
it works
in these
presidential news conferences,
you get one question
to each leader.
So to President Trump,
I simply asked him,
I said, you know, the U.S.
Intelligence officials,
all of them,
say that Moscow,
Russia interfered
with the 2016 election.
Vladimir Putin,
the man standing next to you
just denied it.
Who do you believe?
And he pretty clearly signaled
that he believed Russia,
that he did not believe
the assessment
of his own intelligence
agencies.
And then my question
to Vladimir Putin was,
did the Russians have
any compromising material
on Donald Trump or his family?
You may recall there was some
salacious rumors back then
as to stuff they may or may not
have had, some kompromat,
and I will note as Putin
answered the question,
and by the way,
when he talks to you,
he doesn't break eye contact.
It's pretty terrifying
and I made sure not to have --
I made sure not to have any tea
or step near a window
or a set of stairs
the rest of the day.
He gave a long answer about
how it would be very challenging
to collect compromising material
on every prominent
American who comes to Russia.
He never actually denied it.
And I will say a postscript,
obviously,
that moment,
the Helsinki news conference,
was seen as one very damaging
for Donald Trump.
Even some of his allies
in the Republican Party
turned on him and said
they couldn't believe --
I think John McCain
used the word "traitorous."
That we got back on Air Force
One -- I was part
of the presidential pool,
so I was traveling with him
back to Washington,
and he got on the plane
and had thought
he had done well.
And as soon as he turned
on Fox News,
he was disabused of that notion
and grew so angry
that aides later told me
that he was so anxious
to get home,
you know how planes sometimes,
the pilot will tell you,
"Well, we can make up
some time in the air."
Air Force One really has
the ability to do that.
[ Laughter ]
And we shaved about two hours
off our flight
time from Finland.
The plane was like shaking
on the way back,
and we're all hanging on
as he was looking
to put this behind him.
-Now, I want to ask.
Something obviously you've been
reporting on last week
and into this week is the
classified documents situation.
Obviously,
we were all well aware
of what had happened
with the documents
that former president Trump
was keeping at Mar-A-Lago.
And now, we're having obviously
a far smaller amount
of documents,
but real classified documents
that were in President Biden's
possession.
What -- How do you see
this story unfolding?
Do you see this as a sort of
universal idea
that keeping classified material
is bad
or do you see it developing
into sort of a partisan story
where we're losing our focus?
-Yeah, we're certainly
covering this every day,
both on MSNBC and Politico.
And it is much more
of a political story
than it is a legal one
for President Biden.
There's certainly, at least
from what we know of now,
and it's still developing,
we're still learning about it.
It seems that there's about
a dozen or so documents
seemingly inadvertently
packed away
where they shouldn't have been.
And to be clear, the classified
material should not be
in the garage of a home
in Wilmington, Delaware,
that's never okay.
But there's no sense of intent
that it was done deliberately,
and President Biden,
unlike his predecessor,
has not been accused of trying
to willfully obstruct efforts
to get that material back.
So we have now descended
into very much a partisan story
though national security
implications to be clear,
classified materials,
that matters,
that's serious stuff,
but this is much more
about politics
and we're seeing
from a lot of Republicans,
I mean, hypocrisy,
there's no other way to say it.
They didn't care much at all
about the hundreds
upon hundreds of documents
found at Mar-A-Lago.
They seem to care quite a bit
about this dozen
or so found
in Delaware and D.C.
-Another hypocrisy you've
pointed out
is they are sort of raising
a ruckus
about the fact that there were
no visitor logs
for who came to President
Biden's home
in Wilmington, Delaware.
But this is obviously,
if you were a supporter
of President Trump,
this would be the sort of
height of hypocrisy
because visitor logs
weren't really his thing.
-They were not.
I mean, first of all,
for any president,
it's a personal residence.
Visitor logs are not kept,
whether it's President
Biden's home,
Wilmington, Delaware,
President Obama's
home in Chicago,
President Bush's home in Texas
or any of President
Trump's homes,
Mar-A-Lago,
Bedminster,
Trump Tower, et cetera.
But more than that,
President Trump did away
with the tradition
of releasing visitor
logs at the White House itself.
So it is very much one
where Republicans don't really
have a credible leg to stand on.
-He's not watching right now,
but if President
Trump was watching --
[ Laughter ]
I think he would like what you
just said because he'd be like,
"Did you hear
I had a lot of houses?"
[ Laughter ]
"Do you hear how he mentioned
only one Obama?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's true.
-"He had to mention
like a bunch of mine.
He missed a few.
[ Laughter ]
There's a story,
obviously it's being covered.
I think that people maybe
haven't quite wrapped
their heads around how insane
this George Santos story is.
This is a freshman
Republican Congressman
from New York
who was elected,
and then his personal biography
just seems every day
is falling apart even more.
Maybe hadn't told a single truth
about himself.
Have you ever seen
anything quite like this?
-Do you have a favorite
George Santos lie?
-I -- I mean, Jew --
saying you're Jewish
and then backing off
and clarifying
that you meant you were
the "ish."
Personally, I found that one
very --
-That's classic.
Another 10 out of 10
no-notes lie
is that he claimed to be
a volleyball star
at Baruch College
that won a championship.
That part's true. Baruch College
won a championship.
He had nothing to do with it.
He wasn't on the team.
He didn't go to the school.
But more than that
that he played so hard,
he had to have
double knee replacement.
He had to have both knees
replaced, a man in his 30s.
He seems pretty spry as he's
trying to evade
reporters in Capitol Hill
hallways.
But to your point,
it is remarkable.
Certainly we live --
We've never had a politician
lie A to Z about his biography.
George Santos has done that,
if that is his real name.
[ Laughter ]
And what we -- But in some ways,
it almost seems like the natural
evolution of the Trump era.
A figure who so much of
his career was built on lies.
And then of course from his
campaign to his administration,
he would so distrust
with institutions
by telling lie
after lie after lie,
and of course, most of all
about the 2020 election,
which is what I covered
in my book.
In some ways, Santos is like,
"Well, he got inspiration."
-[ Laughs ]
Absolutely.
How do you see it ending?
Do you think he's going
to stick it out?
-Well, the biggest surprise
to me in terms of the day-to-day
is the fact there have been
some of his fellow
Republicans who have called
for him to resign,
including those in New York,
as well as Nassau County --
that's where he represents,
Long Island --
that Republican Party
have said, "You should go."
He is saying he won't.
But an element --
at a time of such great
partisanship,
the fact that any Republicans
are willing to say
he should go is noteworthy.
That said, Republican leadership
in the House,
they're not doing so.
They're even giving him
a committee assignment.
Kevin McCarthy can't afford
a single vote.
And the other lesson that Santos
seemed to learn from Trump --
you never apologize,
you never say you're sorry,
you don't quit.
He thinks he can ride it out.
-Yeah, he learned all of that
from his volleyball coach.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-One last thing to ask you
about, which is sports,
we are Boston sports fans.
You're a Boston Red Sox fan.
You are raising children
in New York City.
This is a great fear of mine.
Ours are a little younger.
They haven't committed.
But do you ever worry they're
going to come home one day
with some Yankee paraphernalia
or tell you this is the team
that they have chosen
to throw their life behind?
-I mean, they know the stakes.
They'd be disowned.
-Yeah, okay.
-So no, there's no chance.
They are being raised
as Red Sox fans,
I've lived in New York
a long time.
It has done nothing to diminish
my fandom
for the Red Sox.
In fact, living among
Yankee fans every day just makes
me dislike them so much more.
-Yeah, I agree.
[ Laughter ]
And it was all worth it
to live here in 2004.
-Was it ever, oh, was it ever.
-That was the time of my life.
-And my kids know, as wonderful
as it was when they were born,
that's second place to 2004.
-Everything's been downhill
since then.
You guys,
that's Jonathan Lemire.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Way Too Early" airs weekdays
at 5:00 a.m. on MSNBC.